Hello everyone, this
is a neuropathology
lecture on
demyelinating diseases.
And these are the
session objectives,
which should be the
same as in your CPG.
These are the
selected topics
that you'll be tested on.
I have other topics
in here, but those are
for board studying
and other things, but
these are the main
ones here listed here.
Okay, so just going over
the basics of
demyelination.
we're meaning loss of
myelin basically and
in the great amount
of cases the axons are
preserved okay the
myelin is lost which
is the sheath around
the axons but the axons
are preserved and
that's helpful in
distinguishing uh
demyelinating things from
things like infarct
because in infarct you're
going to have loss of
everything not just
the myelin but also
the axons so that's
something to keep in
mind but i do want to
emphasize that if
the demyelination is
severe you can uh
eventually destroy the axons
okay this is a lot
of physics here which
i'm not going to go
into but basically
the point of myelination
in um the nervous
system is because of
saltatory conduction.
Okay, they jump. They
jump. The impulses
jump. And if you have
this nicely intact myelin
sheath, impulses are
much easier to go down
because of the saltatory
conduction. Here's
another picture where
you have on top a
very nice saltatory
conduction. The action
potential goes down.
Everything is fine. But
in demyelination, that
does not happen. So
we know that the
velocity that the action
potential travels down
the axon depends on the
myelination and the
diameter of the fiber.
You can have some
local current flow
in unmyelinated
fibers but the better
way, the faster way,
is the saltatory
conduction in
myelinated fibers.
Okay let's start out
with a case that I
will introduce the
first topic. 33 year old
woman complains of
urinary incontinence and
blurry vision for the
past three months.
Fundoscopic exam
shows no problems. Two
months later she
develops double vision
and numbness in the
fingers of her left
hand and an MRI shows
scattered plaques
in both the brain
and the spinal cord.
Some of these plaques
over time diminish
in size and others
appear in new locations.
So these plaques
would most likely show
selective loss of which
of the following proteins.
So this is just
an introduction to
demyelination and obviously
the answer here I hope
you would figure out
is D as in David myelin
because we haven't
yet talked about beta
amyloid which is a
something in Alzheimer's
disease or synaptopheicin
or alphacinaclean
which would be Parkinson's
disease. So the
answer here is D and
I'm using this question
to introduce multiple
sclerosis. Multiple
sclerosis is an autoimmune
demyelinating disorder
and it's chronic. So
you get episodes of
neurological problems,
deficits that are
separated in time and
separated in space. There's
patchy white matter
lesions. This is the
most common demyelinating
disorder and usually
it can happen at any
age, but childhood
or after 50 is rare.
And women are affected
twice as often as men,
which makes sense,
especially because it's
an autoimmune disease.
There's a varying
clinical course. It
could be relapsing and
remitting episodes.
It could be weeks,
months, years,
and gradual and
partial recovery of
neurological function or
possible deterioration.
Again, every case
is different.
So the problem
here is that the
autoimmune
response is against
parts of the
myelin sheath.
This disease has
both genetic and
environmental factors
that contribute
to it, like many
diseases do.
The incidence of
multiple sclerosis is
15 times higher if a
first degree relative
has it. So that is
definitely a genetic
predisposition.
There happens to be a
strong association
with the DR haplotype
of the major
histocompatibility complex.
There's other
associations as well with
interleukin-2 and 7
receptor genes, and
that's all involved in
the immune response.
Now, the environmental
factors, it's
interesting that
geographic variation
occurs in multiple
sclerosis so that there
are much higher
cases away from the
equator, diagnosed
away from the equator.
And they think
maybe that has to do
with low level
vitamin D, which does
kind of modulate
the immune system.
But again, these
things are not
definitive, but
there definitely is a
geographic variation.
So the more north
you go, the higher
the level, and as
you get to the
equator, decreased.
Okay, so the pathogenesis
basically right
now, as the evidence
available, we have
from the early
2020s, which was only
a couple years ago, is
that MS is initiated
by T helper 1 and T
helper 17 T cells,
and that react against
myelin antigens.
In doing so, they
secrete cytokines.
The Th1 cells secrete
interferon gamma,
and if you remember,
interferon gamma
activates macrophages,
and the Th17 cells
promote recruitment
of white blood cells.
So deionation
occurs because the
activated white blood
cells have products
that are injurious
to the myelin.
When you look at the
infiltrate in the
plaques that make up
multiple sclerosis and the
surrounding regions
you will see a lot of
lymphocytes that are
T cells mainly CD4
positive some CD8
positive and macrophages.
There are therapies that
have pharmacologists
talk more to you
about that modulate
or inhibit t-cell
responses to help block
the recruitment of t
-cells to the brain.
There is a suspected
contribution of humoral
immunity because
we will see later
oleclonal bands occur
in the CSF. These are
oleclonal bands of
immunoglobulins. So to
summarize multiple
sclerosis is an autoimmune
disease or appears
to be an autoimmune
disease triggered by
environmental factors
in genetically
susceptible individuals.
I just want to emphasize
this is a white
matter disease.
When the brain is in
the fresh state,
meaning you know we've
taken the brain out
at autopsy and we have
not fixed it in
formalin or anything,
the lesions that you
see, the plaques are
firmer than the
surrounding white matter.
And that's where
the word sclerosis
comes from because
sclerosis means hard.
These are well
circumscribed, sometimes
depressed, gray tan
lesions, and the
actual area of
demyelination is often
has sharply defined
borders. These
can be very small or
can be very large.
The plaques commonly
occur near the lateral
ventricles and often
can occur in the
corpus callosum, optic
nerves, and other
places as listed here.
They can sometimes
extend to the gray
matter, but this is
generally a white matter
disease. Okay, so this
is a fresh brain.
You've got two black
arrows pointing at the
plaques, the multiple
sclerosis plaques,
and these are
periventricular. You see
the ventricles there,
the lateral
ventricles, and they're
very well demarcated,
and if you were to
put a gloved hand on
this, it will feel
firmer than the
surrounding tissue.
Okay, I wanted to
show you this because
the next picture,
and often they're
symmetrical, by the
way, shows a brain.
This is also with
multiple sclerosis, but
this brain has been
fixed in formalin.
So I don't know what
the boards will do
to you, whether
they'll show you fresh
or fixed, but I wanted
to show you both.
The point is that
you can still see
lesions here, but
they look a little bit
different once they're
put in formalin.
What do we see under
the microscope?
Well, sometimes they
refer to active or
acute plaques and inactive
or chronic plaques.
The point is that an
active lesion will
have ongoing myelin
breakdown, and because
the myelin is breaking
down, there's going to
be a lot of foamy
macrophages because myelin
is made up of a lot
of sphingomyelosin,
which is fatty, and
you'll see foamy
macrophages. You're also
going to see lymphocytes,
especially around the
vessels and at the
outer edge of lesions.
The active lesions
are usually around
small veins and myelin
is being destroyed
or completely absent.
Again, most of the time,
axons are preserved.
Now, anything
that happens
in this nervous system,
especially central
nervous system, when
you have something
like this going on,
whether it's loss of
neurons, which we'll
talk about
neurodegenerative or loss of
myelin, you will have
reactive changes. The
astrocytes will become
reactive and you
get what's called
reactive gliosis. Gliosis
is the term that we
use in the CNS that
really means fibrosis.
It means like, it's
used in the, in
replace of the word
fibrosis because there's
no fibrosis really
in the CNS. So the
glial cells become
reactive, and you get
gliosis, not fibrosis.
When the plaques
are not active, when
they're more chronic,
they've been around a
long time, you don't
have the macrophages.
Myelin is gone, pretty
much, and there's going
to be a reduced number
of oligodendrocyte
nuclei, and that
makes sense, because
oligodendrocytes are what
make myelin in the CNS.
and also you'll have
the reactive gliosis as
I mentioned in the more
chronic plaques not
the not the active
ones okay so it depends
on the age of the
plaque what you're going
to see early ones or
whether you call them
active or acute you're
going to see a lot of
myelin breakdown and
phagocytosis as I mentioned
by macrophages and
also inflammatory
mononuclear cells notice
that these are mononuclear
cells which means
lymphocytes mostly
which is kind of a
little strange because we
always think of the
first responder as a
neutrophil but in this
case we have lymphocytes.
Here in the beginning
the lesions are not
you don't have a lot
of gliosis yet and
the axons are spared
but as the lesion
progresses and becomes
more chronic there
will be fewer
inflammatory cells for
your lymphocytes and
a lot more gliosis.
So this is a really
high power of a very
active lesion. I don't
want to say acute
because acute you often
think neutrophils so
we'll call this an
active lesion. Basically
you wouldn't know
what it is if I didn't
tell you. We're really
high up on a plaque,
high power and you're
seeing a lot of blue
dots and those are all
lymphocytes basically
around uh somewhere
in there is a vessel.
Now this is a high
power of a deamyelinated
plaque and what you
see is that there's
less oligodendroglia
and um a lot uh
an increase in the
astrocytic nuclei which
are like the fibrillary
background where
the arrow is there
and this happens to
be near a ventricle
though you cannot see
the ventricle here
this is high power.
okay there are a lot
of different myelin
stains and some of them
are quite pretty this
one is a luxulfast
blue and so myelin will
stain this this royal
blue color as you can
tell in this lesion
which happens to be an
early lesion around a
vein there's there's
no staining around the
vein and that's because
there's no myelin
okay so this is a demy
this is how they prove
the demyelination.
Now in an active lesion
in the plaque you
can do an oil red O
-stain. What is the
point of this? This
is to show you the
fatty or the lipid-laden
macrophages because
oil red will stain
lipids basically
and that's because
of the breakdown of
myelin. Okay the myelin
is breaking down and
that's got you know
what lipids in it
and will be taken up
by the macrophages.
The older plaques or
the chronic lesions
are not going to have
as many mononuclear
cells or lymphocytes
and there's going to be
almost complete
demyelination a lot of
reactive gliosis a lot
okay and we'll talk
more about that in
subsequent lectures there's
going to be
oligodendrocyte loss and if
it's really bad as i
mentioned earlier you
can get axonal loss
although that's not
usually a finding
unless it's very severe.
So these are basically
the same lesion, but
one's H&E, the
irregular hematoxyl and
eosin, and one is the
special myelin stain.
And what you see is
that we've got a lesion
around a vein. Now
we can't see the
ventricle in this
picture, but we do see the
vein right back in the
middle. There isn't
much inflammation and
it's demyelinated.
You see paleness,
lighter pink in the H&E
and total white in the
other myelin stain.
This is a good cartoon
I think because it
helps show what what
I mean by reactive
astrocytes. Normally
there is a bunch of axons
myelinated that a normal
astrocyte is surrounding,
but as it loses its
myelin and you see
over on the right side
there's no more smooth
myelin, it's all
lost, you'll have more
and more reactive
astrocytes, which causes
the gliosis or astrogliosis
that I keep talking
about in demyelinated
axons. So there are
distinct episodes of
neural deficits that
are separated in time
that are attributable
to white matter lesions
separated in space.
How do these
patients present?
A number of
different ways.
Weakness in one or
more limbs, about 40
percent and you can
get motor and sensory
impairment of trunks and
limbs and spasticity.
What's interesting
about this disease is
remember it's not
going to be it's not
going to make sense
in many ways. A
person may say look
I'm having tingling in
my right arm and
I'm having trouble
moving my left leg.
It doesn't make sense
from a neurological
point because there
are different plaques
and different space
and time and that's
that's the point.
One of the frequent
initial manifestations
is something called
optic neuritis where
you get unilateral
visual impairment because
the optic nerve
becomes demyelinated
and these patients
also go on to develop
sensory problems. They
can also have double
vision or vertigo,
bladder dysfunction, and
other things like
that. There are two
things that are clinically
mentioned. They're
old terms but you might
want to know about
them. When the
temperature outside is
higher than usual,
symptoms will get worse
and that's called a
toughs phenomenon and
when there's also
something if you put
the if you ask the
patient to take their
chin and move it down
to their chest or
in other words bending
the neck they will
get this kind of
lightning bolts kind
of feeling an electrical
sensation that
runs down their back
called limited sign.
Okay if you do a CSF
tap on these people,
on these patients, I'm
sorry, you're gonna
have protein levels
that are moderately
elevated and moderate
pleocytosis in about
a third of cases.
What does pleocytosis
mean? It means there's
an increase in white
blood cells of the
mononuclear type, so
lymphocytes. Now there's
going to be also an
increase in immunoglobulins.
Remember this
is an autoimmune
disease and very
significantly, there's
an oloclonal, there's
oloclonal IgG bands that
you do that based on
immunoelectrophoresis.
And that's very
characteristic of
multiple sclerosis. And
that proves that
there's a, or at least
it seems that there's
a presence of a small
number of activated
B cell clones in
the CNS, though these
are thought to be
self-reactive. If you
did evoked response
testing, you might
detect slowing,
interruption of conduction
in many different
pathways, whether it
be sensory or motor.
An MRI is, I think,
at this time still the
preferred way to
follow the disease. The
treatment consists of
immunosuppression or
immunomodulatory agents,
which I won't discuss in
this lecture. I'm sure
you'll get a pharmacology
lecture on that.
And again, they slow
the progression but
not really cure the
disease. So this is hard
to diagnose sometimes.
You have to recognize
that signs and symptoms
represent different
lesions and different
spots and different ages
so they're separated
by time and space that's
what I keep saying
these are this is an
MRI it is the preferred
method I believe of
imaging the brain I
say I believe because
I'm not a radiologist
I'm a pathologist but
this is what's used and
the the reason why
is because brains can
appear normal on CT in
MS, but you can see the
plaques on the MRI
as seen here. You can
see the white spots here
on this side anyway.
The diagnosis can't
be made though just on
MRI and that's important
because you can have
other neurological
diseases that look similar
and if you have a
normal MRI that does
not rule out the diagnosis
of multiple sclerosis
because about 5% of
patients who have MS
based on other
criteria, clinical and
oligoclonal bands, etc.
don't show plaques on MRI.
So that's important
to know. It's a small
percentage, but it is.
Okay, I want to talk
a little bit about
this. It used to be that
they would divide into
little groups as far
as clinical progression,
four main groups.
I spoke to Dr. Lader,
who's our neuro
neurologist, and
apparently the fourth one,
progressive relapsing,
is no longer used in the
literature. So I want
to make that clear. What
happens is that the
disease, most of the
disease, can be relapsing
remitting. So that,
what does that mean?
That means discrete
attacks or discrete
flares and they resolve
over weeks or months and
they do not progress.
Then there's primary
progressive and secondary
progressive. Primary
progressive is
chronic progression
obviously from the start
and secondary progression
progressive is
relapsing and remitting
initially and then gradual
progression and eventual
permanent disability.
Now progressive
relapsing as I said is
no longer a term that is
used in the literature
and though they do
have other terms such
as clinically
isolated syndrome and
radiologically isolated
syndrome. This is just to
let you know that not
every case of multiple
sclerosis follows the
same clinical path.
Okay, I want to mention
these three. I will
not test you on them,
but I think it's
important to know
because in the CNS-D
myelinating diseases,
it's not just multiple
sclerosis, even though
that's the most common.
So these three are
neuromyelitis optica,
acute disseminated
encephalomyelitis, and
acute necrotizing hemorrhagic
encephalomyelitis.
so in neuromyelitis
optica you have
bilateral optic
neuritis and spinal cord
demyelination at the same
time it was considered
a variant of multiple
sclerosis but now it's
considered to be a
distinct disorder and
it usually has is more
commonly associated
with poor recovery from
the first attack and
one thing that is
associated with is aquaporin
for antibodies
the next one Acute
disseminated
encephalomyelitis is
not a good disease.
Diffuse monophasic
demyelinating disease.
It usually follows
a viral infection or
sometimes immunization,
viral immunization.
Symptoms will occur
one or two weeks later.
People develop
headaches, lethargy, and
coma and unfortunately
this is a rapid clinical
course and has a high
mortality rate of
20% and some patients
will remain you know
disabled and some will
recover completely.
Acute necrotizing
hemorrhagic encephaly
myelitis it sounds as bad
as it is it's really a
fulminant syndrome and
it happens in young
adults and children
usually preceded by an
upper respiratory infection
of an unknown cause
and it can be fatal
and the survivors can
have significant
deficits. So I mention you
this to just make a
complete story in the
demyelinating diseases.
I mentioned this because
this comes up a lot in
medicine, the central
pontine myelonosis,
also known as osmotic
demyelination syndromes.
This happens when
you rapidly correct
hyponatremia, okay, or
any other severe
electrolyte disturbance or
osmolar imbalance. So
acutely what happens is
there's loss of myelin
and it's in the base
of the ponds and roughly
in a symmetric pattern
and that's what you
see there on the
bottom where there's two
black they well first
the picture in the
middle you see the white
arrow and the two
black arrows and in the
picture over on the right
and you see a little
inset here blue
again is the
myelin this is
the ponds and that
white area is
demyelination.
So they don't know
why increases in
osmolality or the
rapid correction, the
mechanisms are not
thoroughly established.
They do know there's
no inflammation
and that the neurons and
axons are pretty
well preserved.
And all the lesions,
because it's
synchronous onset
of damage, will be
at the same stage
of myelin loss and
reaction. That's
different than MS.
And it can involve
most parts of
the brain, but
mostly it's the pons.
What happens
is a clinically
rapidly evolving
quadriplegia,
and that's not
very good at all.
Fatal or long-term
deficits, and the patients
will develop the locked
-in syndrome where
they're fully conscious
but cannot move. It's
horrible. It's absolutely
horrible. So the
take-home message,
which this one is
hyponatremia must
be corrected slowly
and carefully.
So I wanted to mention
this one as well.
Here's a case question
to bring up the
next topic of
demyelination and this is a
41 year old woman who
has a flu-like illness
for one week and
later she experiences
a rapidly progressive
ascending motor
weakness which we'll
talk more about what
that means and
requires intubation and
mechanical ventilation.
They do a CSF tap,
and there's clear
colorless spinal fluid
under normal pressure
with a slightly
elevated protein
concentration, normal
glucose levels, and
only a few lymphocytes.
Now, so again,
this does not sound
like meningitis
because you would
have a cloudy
fluid in white
blood cells, a lot
of neutrophils.
In this case, the patient
recovered in three
weeks. Now, If, and
you don't go around
doing biopsies on this
case, if lymphocyte
infiltrates were seen
in the peripheral
nerves along with
segmental demyelination,
what would be the most
likely diagnosis? This
is a first order
question that you're not
likely to get, but
it's the point is I'm
trying to introduce
this disease. And what
this disease is, is
not multiple sclerosis.
We haven't talked
about ALS or the others
yet, but Guillain
-Barre syndrome, D as in
David, is the answer
here. So what is Guillain
-Barre syndrome? The
other name is acute
inflammatory demyelinating
polyneuropathy.
It's very acute
onset and it's immune
mediated and it's in the
peripheral neuropathy.
It's not in the
brain, it's periphery.
That's the difference.
It can lead to fatal
life-threatening
respiratory paralysis and
the weakness will
begin distally and then
rapidly goes proximally.
That's what an
ascending paralysis
is. So they have distal
problems and then it
becomes more proximal.
If you were to look
at a peripheral nerve
that is involved, you
will see inflammation,
lymphocytes, and
segmental demyelination
of spinal roots and
the peripheral nerves.
Again, two-thirds
of the cases
can be preceded
by an acute kind
of viral illness
like the flu,
or flu-like I should
say, and they have
had studies where
their infections with
things like CMV and
Campylobacter and
EBV and mycoplasma
pneumonia and prior
vaccination are
also associated with
Guillain-Barre, but as
of yet has not found
an infectious agent
in the nerves.
So you're going to have
this inflammation of
the nerves and the
infiltrated lymphocytes
and macrophages maybe
a few plasma cells but
not neutrophils okay
again it's not neutrophils
segmental demyelination
means there's
demyelination in
segments and it affects
peripheral nerves the
damage to axons if severe
there is damage to axons
but the most lichen
ms is mostly preserved
and schwann cells
are preserved now why
am i mentioning schwann
cells and cell
oligodendrocytes because
Schwann cells are the
myelinating cells of the
peripheral nervous
system whereas the
oligodendrocytes do the
central nervous system. If
you did electron
microscopy you would see
the myelin sheath already
being affected and
again I usually don't
use electron microscopy
but that tells you
how it's showing that
they're stripping of
the myelin sheath from
the axon so eventually
you'll get the myelin
sheath engulfed by
macrophages and you'll
get the inflammation
and demyelination which
can be quite widespread
so this is another
pretty myelin stain where
basically the myelin
stains pink or magenta
and the green is
loss of myelin and
you see here this is a
peripheral nerve again
you don't usually do
biopsies on these but
this is what it would look
like and here's another
picture of a very
high power of basically
all the lymphocytes
in the inflammation in
in the peripheral nerve
and you do see residual
myelinated axons
if you see the black
arrow over here on the
left and it shows a
very pink very pink line
those are axons that
are preserved and the
white bubbly appearing
stuff surrounding them
are the myelin sheaths
some of which are
there and some of which
are gone so that's
why it's demyelinating.
So again please remember
the ascending paralysis
and reflexes there
are no areflexia
deep tendon reflexes
usually disappear
that's another important
clinical sign there can
be sensory involvement
loss of pain sensation,
that can be very
prominent. If you did nerve
conduction velocities,
they would be slowed
down because there's
multifocal destruction
of myelin segments.
CSF levels, the
protein levels will be
elevated because
there's inflammation and
altered permeability
of the circulation,
the microcirculation
in the spinal roots.
But the inflammatory
cells are kind of
confined to the roots
and you really don't
get much CSF pleocytosis
or inflammation.
Many patients
can spend weeks
in the intensive
care unit before
recovering, if
they recover.
Nowadays, we have
better ICUs, better
supportive respiratory
care, cardiovascular
monitoring, so the
mortality rate isn't
as bad as it used to
be, but can be high.
Plasmapheresis and IV
immunoglobulin therapy
is helpful because
what do they do? They
remove the antibodies
and suppress the
immune function. Despite
this two to five percent
of patients will
die eventually of
respiratory paralysis
or cardiac arrest or
something else like
autonomic instability and
up to 20% of patients
who do end up in the
hospital will suffer
long-term disability.
Okay now we're
going to move on to
leukodystrophies and I'm
only going to mentioned
three there are many
many different types
these are genetic
metabolic disorder and
rather than demyelinating
the books like to
refer them as dysmyelinating
because the myelin
is forming but it's
abnormal in formation
and the myelin is not
stable so the myelin
isn't damaged but
the way it's formed
is is abnormal and in
general leukodystrophies
are insidious and
progressive and usually
happen in children,
especially infants,
and are a result of
lysosomal or perioxosomal
enzyme defects. It
can involve both the
central and the
peripheral nervous system.
Unfortunately, these
are progressive
diseases that result in
death at an early age.
And the earlier
onset, the more severe
clinically. So this is
biochemistry. And what
you see here are
reactions and the green
ones are the things to
remember well the red
is the disease name
and the green are the
enzymes that are
deficient so we're going
to talk about metachromatic
leukodystrophy
and crabb's disease
and also another one
the al sulfatase a is
the enzyme deficiency
in metachromatic
leukodystrophy and
galactocerebroside beta
galactocerebrosidase I
wish there was an
acronym for that. I don't
know it though, is
the one in Crabb's
disease that's deficient.
So let's talk first
about metachromatic
leukodystrophy. This
is an autosomal
recessive disease. I told
you these were genetic
and the lysosomal
enzyme that is deficient
is aryl sulfatase
A. What that enzyme
normally does is cleaves
sulfate from sulfate
containing lipids.
And that leads to, if
you don't have that
enzyme, you will lead
to accumulation of
sulfatides, okay?
Especially cerebriside
sulfate, which is
toxic to white matter.
So demyelination will
result in gliosis because
gliosis is a reactive
change in the nervous
system. You'll see
macrophages with
vaculated cytoplasms. And
the interesting thing,
why is is called
metachromatic but remember
the word metaplasia
change well metachromatic
means a change in
color okay so basically
there are membrane
bound vacuoles that have
these crystalloid
structures is made of
sulfatides when they bind
certain kinds of dyes
the sulfatides will
shift the spectrum the
absorbent spectrum so
they change color that's
what metachromasia
is so you get a blue
dye that comes out.
It's blue when you when
you use it and then it
comes out looking red.
This similar metachromatic
stuff happens in
peripheral nerves and
in urine and in fact
they do a urine test
which is a sensitive
method for diagnosis.
There are many clinical
subtypes which we
will not go into but
in this case we've got
a slide, a stain which
was originally cressyl
violet would have
been a nice deep purple
and with this disease
it stains this this
red this deep red.
The next one crabby
disease or globoid cell
leukodystrophy is also
autosomal recessive
and the enzyme deficiency
like I mentioned
is galactocerebroside
beta-galactosidase.
You need this enzyme
for catabolism of
galactocerebroside to the
ceramide and galactose.
because you don't
have that enzyme
and you have the
impaired catabolism
you'll have
alternate catabolic
pathways and that shunts
the galactosurubicide
to
galactosphilosphingosine
then you get the
elevated levels of the
galactosphilosphingosine
which is
toxic to oligodendrocytes
and the brain
will show loss of myelin
and oligodendrocytes
and also the
peripheral nerves
The diagnostic feature
is these globoid
cells or globoid cells,
which are aggregation
of engorged macrophages
in the brain and
around the blood
vessels. Now, obviously,
this is usually
autopsy, but that's what
you would see on the
tissue. And this is
a section of brain
that was affected by
Krabs disease. And you
see basically the blue
arrows are showing
the globoids. They
look like globes or
something like that. And
the black arrow is
just showing gliosis,
again, the astrocytes
that are reactive.
The last one I want
to talk about is
adrenoleukodystrophy,
which is not autosomal
or something. It is
excellent recessive,
and I believe was the
subject of a movie
many, many years ago
called Lorenzo's Oil.
Here, there's loss of
function mutations
in ABCD1.
Okay, what is ABCD1?
Well, it encodes
an ATP binding
cassette transporter
protein. You need that to
transport fatty
acids into paroxomes.
So usually these
are boys that are
affected and they
will have behavioral
changes and adrenal
insufficiency.
And the loss of this
ABCD1 also leads to
inability to catabolize
very long chain fatty
acids. So in their
serum, the boys will have
elevated serum levels
of very long chain
fatty acids. The
symptoms are progressive.
They involve the
adrenal gland as well as
the CNS and the PNS.
And you'll have CNS
myelin loss. And
along with myelin loss
is gliosis and
lymphocytic infiltration.
And there will be
adrenal cortical
atrophy. So they
will lose cortisol.
This is another
myelin stain. And here
again, the white
matter WM is *****
in the middle, and
it's pale because
it's not staining.
The myelin's not
there. It should be
that blue color that
you see over on the
right-hand side.
Okay, I'm not
going to go through
this extensively,
but there are a lot
of other metabolic
genetic diseases.
If you go into
neonatology of
pediatrics, this would
be very important.
Other leukodystrophies
mentioned here
include things like
Alexander disease, and
these are again defects
in lipid metabolism.
Neuronal storage
diseases, there are many.
They are genetically
heterogeneous and
usually they're caused
by enzyme deficits
or defects in protein
or lipids trafficking
in neurons. So you get
the storage material
in the neurons and
the neurons then die.
And the mitochondrial
encephalomyopathies
really are more
relevant in the skeletal
muscle pathology.
These are diseases of
energy generation
caused by a range of
neurological disease
and includes a lot of
different things,
including M-E-L-A-S-M-E-L
-A-S, mitochondrial
encephalomyopathy,
lactic acidosis, and
******-like episodes. So
you can read about
this. Again, it's
important to know that
they exist, and my
understanding is some
of them, like the
mitochondrial ones might
appear on the boards.
Okay, so case question.
We're going to do
a little bit review
here. Six-month
-old girl with
metachromatic leukodystrophy
fails to thrive,
dies of respiratory
insufficiency.
Histo-exam of the
brain at autopsy shows
marked accumulation of
metachromatic material
and in the white
matter and prominent
astrogliosis. So the
lab studies confirm an
accumulation of
cerebrocyte so she has an
inborn error metabolism
which is the deficiency
what enzyme is
deficient so hopefully
i mean the only one
you recognize that i've
talked about in here
is um d as in david
aryl sulfatase a so
and we're told it's
metachromatic leukodystrophy
they wouldn't be
so nice on the boards
they probably say
you know something
changed the color from red
to blue blue to red
another question an
eight-month-old boy
exhibits severe motor
sensory and cognitive
impairments. Brain
biopsy, and they rarely
do that but they can,
shows a disease of white
matter characterized
by the accumulation
of globoid cells.
The biochemical
studies reveal absence
of galactosteroboside
beta-galactosidase.
So what is the
diagnosis? This is a
primary question, a
first-order question
I should say, And
again, it's just
meant to reinforce that
this is crab disease,
crabby disease C,
C as in Charlie.
Another case question,
we have, and this is
now I'm going to
introduce the last topic.
A 27-year-old man
presents with dementia,
weakness, visual loss,
and ataxia one year
after getting a cadaveric
kidney transplant.
Which of the following
is the most likely
cause of this patient's
CNS disorder? Now
this is kind of not
fair because I haven't
discussed it yet.
The point of this
question is that it's
a kidney transplant.
So a 27-year-old man
with a kidney transplant
is going to be
immunosuppressed,
right? That's there on
immunosuppressed agents.
So what I'm trying
to introduce to you
is the disease is not
going to be adrenal
leukodystrophy
or metachromatic
leukodystrophy. We've
already discussed that. I
believe subacute
sclerosing panencephalitis
is something associated
with measles.
So the answer is
D as in David,
progressive multifocal
leukoencephalopathy
or better stated as PML.
This is a viral
encephalitis
that's caused by
a virus. The name
of the virus is
JCPolyomavirus.
Why this happens is
because the virus
will preferentially
infect oligodendrocytes
and because oligodendrocytes
are important
in myelination,
that you'll get
demyelination because
the virus will infect
them. Now, about 65
% of the population
normally has evidence
serologically of
exposure to this virus
by their teen years.
So, immuno-intact
people do not get
this, but the virus
is reactivated
when you're
immunosuppressed, such
as in transplants,
chemotherapy,
AIDS.
So, immunosuppressed
patients are the ones
at risk because you
have to reactivate the
virus. clinically there
are focal symptoms
depending on where it is
and they're progressive
and usually pretty
extensive multifocal
thus the name a
cerebral or cerebellar
demyelinated lesions
that you can see these on
ct or mri you'll see
patches of irregular ill
-defined destruction
of white matter often
it's underneath the
cortex and in the center
you're going to get
those lipid-laden
macrophages again because
those are the ones that
eat up the myelin
which has lipids in it.
At the edge of the
lesions you'll see very
enlarged oligodendrocyte
nuclei because
this virus goes into
the nucleus of the
oligodendrocyte and
you'll get this viral
inclusions. They're glassy
and they're amphiphilic
which means they're
kind of like a both
a pink they're magenta
color basically.
And of course along
with that astrogliosis
sometimes very
bizarre reactive
gliosis. So this is
another myelin stain
which is supposed
to be black but that
you see the white
patches here so
you have demyelination
in this disease.
What you see here are
on top the blue arrow
over in the left hand
corner on the top
is basically an
oligodendrocyte nucleus
that has been affected
by this virus, JC
polyvirus, and it has
this magenta color.
It's amphophilic is
another term for it.
There are very bad
reactive, by bad I'm saying
they look really
ugly, like the black
arrows show these really,
you know, big cells
with really bizarre
looking features. I mean,
if you weren't careful
you would think
they're malignant but
they're not malignant
because there's plenty
of cytoplasm usually
malignancy the nuclear
cytoplasmic ratio is
reduced so these are
just very reactive uh
strange bizarre astrogliosis
cells if you did
em these are what the
jc virus particles look
like within the
oligodendroglial nucleus
they're all these little
viral particles So
this is the summary
slide. I believe there are
two and the lecture
feedback form. Thank
you for your attention
and please feel free
to email me. You come
by my office and I'll
be happy to answer any
questions. Thank you.